[Music]
when I talk to graduate students in
education policy today two things stand
out one the caliber of their
methodological training and two how
little time they say they spend reading
or thinking broadly about education when
we discuss what they're learning the
answers tend toward the narrow a
historical and well thin for example
those training to research teacher
quality have devoted a remarkably little
attention as to why career ladder models
have failed in the past or even to what
it really means to be an effective
teacher a lack of history and context
can lead researchers to over-interpret
findings or miss obvious caveats just
for instance we should always keep in
mind that higher test scores may reflect
better instruction or just increase test
preparation and that the answer really
matters let's be clear while
methodological chops are great
we need scholars who also possess
historical memory wisdom and judgment
I hope those preparing tomorrow's
researchers can rise to the challenge
what do you think education researchers
need to know let us know in your
comments also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI